[Music]
the new Sony rx100 mark 7 came out on
the sony RX series has been one of my
favorite lines and vlogging cameras for
the longest time but this one finally
has a microphone input jack and i've
been experimenting with a lot of
microphones and this is a little
twenty-five dollar one that I got from
Amazon so right now I'm not using any
microphone this is the onboard
microphone audience you're good finding
a microphone that works it's an
interesting because there are some that
do work and there's some that don't and
what I found is the TRS microphones
worked really well and those are the
ones with only one little ring right
here
there's trrs there's all kinds of
different versions but if you're looking
for it make sure you're searching for
TRS or you're gonna have to use some
sort of an adapter so now let's switch
to this little guy and let you see what
this sounds like but first jeanna say
something hello how are you doing today
that's what Genna sounds like I'm behind
the camera
it's behind it you're in front of the
camera front okay let's plug this in so
the microphone just alpha like that it
looks so silly because it's so small and
tiny but it's perfect for sort of having
a compact look cuz I didn't want to have
any mounts anyone if anything I just
wanted to have a microphone and so far
this one has worked and it's only 25
bucks
jeanna say something hello it's Jenna
I'm back here I'm behind the camera but
what's cool is you can do one of these
so if Jenna's talking hello it's Jenna
behind the camera or even if you're
buying camera this look at this I'm
still behind a camera I'm moving further
away from you now you say something
Oh the next test that I'm gonna do is
this is just a law of microphone this is
one of the Sennheiser microphones and
again this is the TRS input here there's
so many different versions at 3.5
milimeter jacks so not all of those will
work so it sometimes may be a little bit
of trial and error to see what will work
this is where you look super silly but
for simple vlogging this is incredible
and no one else can see how silly you
look well they'll see how silly you look
in real life just not on camera this
probably isn't the microphone that I
would use on a daily basis but it's all
that I had right now so here you go Jen
okay
hello testing testing so and this one is
only picking up one channel of audio yep
you can't go too far again here's what
it sounds like without a microphone and
now we're gonna just switched you this
little Sennheiser microphone jet and I
shot an entire vlog like this like I was
walking around the zoo and going all
these places and this is what I look
like I mean in real life I look crazy
but for you guys
you've got great audio so look see see
great audio how does it sound
you can also adjust the audio levels in
here as well you know any the function
and then I have it in level 15 it's
basically when I was talking I didn't
want it to peak I was watching my video
from the zoo I realized my audio was
speaking a little bit so about 15 16
seems pretty good as long as it's not
going into the red anyway I'll be doing
a full video of this but I wanted to
give you guys a little taste of the
microphone input in a lot of you guys
were asking me some questions so look
for that video here in the next few days
and I don't know
I can't wait maybe instead of logging in
because this makes blogging easy got a
flip up camera screen screen the only
things they don't know place to mount
the microphone so you have to get
creative there's a bunch of different
brackets that I got so I'll show you
guys some of those vlogging setups but
for now let's finish this hike Jen okay
let's go yeah we still going it's good
that silly silly zoning
[Music]